SPEAKER 1: Here's
exclusive footage
of a film now being made
about an abandoned boy
who became a doctor.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- [INAUDIBLE].
When the high school
counselor came
to give us advice
on courses to take,
and here I was number one
student, he looked at me
and said, I'm putting you in
wood shop, where you belong.
But I [INAUDIBLE] I really
want to go to college.
He said, fine, I will put
you in college prep courses,
but I can guarantee
you that you'll fail.
- He's so inspirational.
I want to be just like him.
And he's a
pediatrician and that's
the career I want to go into.
And knowing that he did it
and all the struggles he
went through, it motivates me.
And I'm like, I can do it.
- I heard his story for the
first time in middle school
when he came to speak
at my middle school
and I was really inspired.
He'd been my doctor my whole
life and I had no idea.
It was such an amazing story.
And then he made
me also want to,
after I complete the
career goal I want to get,
which is orthopedic
surgery, I want
to come back to the
community just like he did.
- An abandoned boy who grew
up working his whole childhood
in the fields to support himself
and contribute to the household
became a physician and
went back to the same area
he grew up in and has
been treating kids there
for 30 years.
That's an important story,
a story that you're changed
and your opinion is changed,
and your even self image
is changed when you walk away.
Now you've seen a movie.
Now you've been to the movies.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
DIANE WAGNER: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for having us.
I thought I'd begin today by
reading a quote about you,
Dr. Resa, that was written
by author and speaker Jim
Cathcart.
"Ramon's story is the
story of human potential,
the unique personal
potential that
exists within us, independently
from any external source.
We are not limited by our age,
our health, our relationships,
or our finances nearly as much
as by our own unwillingness
to dream and persist.
Ramon, you are a unique
and gifted individual
with an important
place in history.
Your legacy will be felt
for many generations,
maybe even forever."
So Jim Cathcart obviously
gets your story,
and so do we, the filmmakers.
And I think the gist of
what really gets to us
is that it really does show
the almost unlimited potential
of every human being and
of the average person.
So I think we can
all relate to that
and I think it's incredibly
important and inspiring,
and that's why we're making
the movie about your story.
RAMON RESA: Thank you.
DIANE WAGNER: All right.
Well, let's start by
talking about your family.
Because your story is incredible
and it begins with your family.
So you didn't know who
your father was and you
were given away by your mother.
Tell us a little bit
about your sense of family
or how you consider
family to be in your life.
RAMON RESA: Well, my mother had
five kids before she was 21.
And she gave us all
away, even though we all
had the same father.
And to this day, I still
don't know who my father is.
She died a couple of years ago.
Before she died, we asked
her, who is our father?
And she refused to tell
us, even though we--
I said she had five kids.
I didn't realize I had a
couple of siblings because she
didn't tell us that either, and
I didn't find out about them
until I was in my 20's.
As far as other
siblings, have no idea,
because I don't know
who my father is.
But she gave us away
to a family of 15.
She told us they were our
grandparents, which found out
that one of them was a
grandparent, but the other one,
not sure where he came from.
So they had 15 in that family.
And they basically just
took us in because they
needed more field workers
to pick the crops.
So the more hands you had at
that time, the better you did.
So that's how I ended up
in Goshen, California.
DIANE WAGNER: So Goshen
is a very tiny town.
Can you kind of paint
a picture of what
that was like for you in the
'50s when you grew up there?
RAMON RESA: Well, when I grew up
in Goshen in the '50s and '60s,
it was poverty,
all farm workers.
You were considered rich if
you actually had an indoor job.
And we all strived
to get an indoor job.
That was our goal.
If we could get
a factory job, we
considered that we made it in
life, because we were always
told that all we were good
for was to be farm workers.
And a step up was getting
out of that hot sun.
Getting out of
that cold weather.
When you're picking
cotton and it's foggy
and when you're picking
oranges and it's foggy and cold
and the fruit still
has ice on them,
or you're picking grapes under
the grapevines and it's 105.
You're hot and sweaty
and black widows
and wasps all over the place.
You're going to get out
into the environment
where it's controlled.
DIANE WAGNER: Right.
So later on in
your life when you
wanted to get a summer
job and things like that,
you wanted an indoor job, right?
And you couldn't get one.
RAMON RESA: Yeah.
I decided to apply as a
stock boy at JC Penny's.
And I went up and I asked.
And they said, well, you
don't have any job experience.
Here I worked 12 hours
a day every summer,
every holiday since the
age of three years of age,
and I was told I had
no job experience
to even be a stock boy.
Of course, at those days, if
you were Mexican or a minority,
they didn't give you those jobs.
They saved those jobs for
people who had some influence
or who knew somebody
at the store.
And of course, being a farm
worker, you don't know anybody.
DIANE WAGNER: Wow.
OK.
Well, let's talk a little
bit more about your family.
So you said you didn't
know your father.
You never knew him, you didn't
know anything about him.
What do you think
that did to you
as a child in terms of your
developing and growing up?
RAMON RESA: When you
don't have a father--
when I became a father, I
wanted to be around for my kids
and play with them and
show them the world.
And growing up, I
had nothing of that.
All I was told is get out
there and work in the fields.
Get up that ladder
and pick the oranges
or get under those grapes.
And who cares if there are
wasps and black widows?
That was my role model,
work, work, work.
There was no fun.
I don't remember
playing at all as a kid.
It was just work.
So I had no concept
of how to be a father,
so when I had my own kids, I
was afraid of screwing them
up the way I was screwed up.
DIANE WAGNER: So you are
afraid, but you always
knew at the same time that you
wanted to have kids, right?
RAMON RESA: I wanted to have
kids because I wanted to--
if I ever had
kids, I wanted them
to have a different
world than I had
and to give them the
opportunity that I didn't have.
To be a kid,
really, to be a kid.
DIANE WAGNER: And you
certainly have done that.
I mean, your kids are the
American success story as well.
Your son has followed
your footsteps.
RAMON RESA: Well, when I
graduated from junior high,
I was the number one student.
They called me into
the office and said,
because of your speech
impediment, and other reasons,
we're not going let you
be the valedictorian.
We're going to let
somebody else do that.
And I thought, that's
great, because I
don't want to get in front
of an audience anyway.
I hate to be in
front of a public.
So when my son graduated
from junior high,
he was the number one student.
He became the valedictorian.
He graduated top of his
class in high school.
He graduated and went
to Stanford University.
He was accepted to UCC San
Francisco Medical School.
And he just finished
his residency training
in pediatrics at
Brown University.
And this is despite
the fact that he always
told me he was never
going to be a doctor
and follow in my footsteps.
He will be actually
starting a fellowship
in New York at Sloan
Kettering next year
in pediatric
hematology oncology.
So I hate him because
life for him was so easy
going through school.
And I suffered so much
and I struggled so much.
DIANE WAGNER: And
you paid for him too.
RAMON RESA: One of
the things I love
to tell people is
I went to college
and I had grants
and scholarships
and working my butt off.
I mean, I worked
every summer holidays
to pay what my
parents were supposed
to pay their side of
the college expenses.
So when my daughter ended
up going to college,
she went to UC Santa
Cruz like my wife
and I did, and I was proud to
pay for her college expenses.
And I made the mistake of
telling my son that if he got
accepted to Harvard
or MIT or Stanford
that I would pay his way.
He received a full ride at UCLA
and Berkeley, but idiot me,
I did make that
comment, and I promised,
so I was proud to pay for him
to attend Stanford University.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE WAGNER: All
right, so that'd
be one of your weaknesses.
RAMON RESA: What's that?
DIANE WAGNER: That
you speak out of hand
and get yourself in trouble.
RAMON RESA: Exactly.
I do that all the time and
then I have to pay the price.
DIANE WAGNER: So
one of the things
that we're going
to do in the film
is when some of your
problems intersect
with societal problems,
we're going to touch on that
and talk about that.
So one of those
issues is hunger.
And you grew up
hungry as a child.
And right now, there are
about 13 million kids
in this country who are hungry.
So I want to know what that's
like, because I've never
been hungry, like
really never hungry.
And I just want to hear what
that was like growing up
and how that impacted you.
RAMON RESA: The
first time I ever
felt that I had enough to eat
was my first day in college.
The cafeteria.
When you go up
there and they say,
oh, you can have all
the food you can eat.
I thought, wow, and
so I loaded up my tray
and I got three glasses
of chocolate milk
because at home we
couldn't ever afford to buy
chocolate and stuff like that.
So I was in heaven.
But when you grow
up poor, I mean,
and 15 kids in the
family, food runs out.
I remember being down to
our last sack of beans
and working in the
winter and when
there was a freeze a number of
times where we couldn't work,
so there was no food.
And luckily, people
dropped food off
at our doorstep, beans and rice
and flour for the tortillas.
And that's what we survived on.
And now my biggest joy is
to do that for other people.
To buy some beans
and rice and flour
and give it to food
pantries, because they feed
the people that were like me.
And I just remember
being hungry all the time
and going out and trying
to study and work at school
and do well educationally.
I just-- because I was hungry.
And here I am picking
grapes and picking oranges
and picking all these crops.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah,
I can't imagine that.
You're picking the food that
we eat and yet you can't eat it
and you're hungry.
RAMON RESA: My grandfather was
really good at raising animals.
We had rabbits and
chickens and goats.
So we were able to sustain
ourselves in mean times
because he always had something.
And he was able to get
the food for those animals
by the leftovers in the
fields that we picked.
DIANE WAGNER: So you lived
basically on rice and beans
and tortillas.
Is that your main?
RAMON RESA: Yep.
That's why I still
love the rice and beans
and tortillas and potatoes.
If somebody wanted to take
me to a fancy restaurant,
the first thing I
look at is, do they
have beans or do they have
rice, do they have tortillas?
So I obviously I
love Mexican food
because that's my comfort food.
That's what I survived on.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
Great.
So as a kid, did you ever
imagine you'd be successful?
RAMON RESA: As a kid,
I was a farm worker
and I was going to
be a farm worker.
I was told that was my life.
So no, I had no clue.
I mean, in my family, if you
graduate from eighth grade,
you're considered intelligent.
And so, I mean,
to go beyond that
and to even think
about going to college
and even when I entertained
the idea of going to college,
people were saying, what do you
want to waste your time for?
Those are only for smart
people or they're only
for white people.
You go out and get a
job in the factory.
So that's what they thought was
considered making it in life.
DIANE WAGNER: So you thought
you could get a factory job?
RAMON RESA: Oh yeah.
Great pay, indoor job.
DIANE WAGNER: So did you
ever dream about other things
though?
Like I don't know, things
you might see on TV or you
might read about, comic books?
RAMON RESA: No, I mean,
because everything you
saw on TV back in those
days, the sitcoms, I mean,
they were all Anglo families
around the table with food
on the table and talking
about their events of the day
in school and all that stuff.
I mean, no, that was not us.
I mean, we could not identify
with that whatsoever.
I mean, that was
so foreign to me
that I looked at that, it
was just a different world.
We didn't exist in the world.
In fact, if you
look at the movies
from those times
and those shows,
the only time we saw a
minority in those shows
was as a janitor or a cook
or a servant, menial jobs.
You didn't them as a
teacher or a parent.
I mean, we had no role
models whatsoever.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah, I get that.
OK, so let's talk about
when you started school.
And when you started school,
you didn't speak English.
And you were told that you could
not speak Spanish in school.
And now I know
that there's a lot
of English as a second
language classes
and bilingual education.
But in those years,
there was none of that.
So I can't imagine how
hard that would have
been to start school like that.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
RAMON RESA: Well, since I
had a lot of older siblings,
I was learning English a little
bit before I went to school.
And it turned out that
my Kindergarten teacher
was Latina, which I didn't
know that, Mrs. [INAUDIBLE],,
because she didn't
speak Spanish.
And then it was just
recently that I realized that
in my whole career in
elementary and high school
and college and medical school
and residency, I never ever
had another Latina teacher.
That was the only one
in my whole career.
DIANE WAGNER: That's unreal.
RAMON RESA: But in
that school, they
did not allow you to speak
Spanish because they thought
that you were talking back.
And so if you were
caught speaking Spanish
in the playground,
they would whack you
over the head with a ruler and
make you stand in the corner,
because that was not allowed.
DIANE WAGNER: Wow.
Did that happen to you?
RAMON RESA: Oh, that
happened all the time,
because you're trying
to talk to somebody
and that's the only
language you know.
And so we made it
to where we did not
want to speak Spanish anymore.
And in fact, for
a while there, I
lost my Spanish because
I just suffocated it
so much that I thought it
was bad to speak Spanish
or to be considered Mexican.
So my name became
Raymond, not Ramon.
DIANE WAGNER: Wow.
So when did you start
using Ramon again?
RAMON RESA: My senior
year in high school.
I started to become more
aware of what we were
and to be proud of our
heritage and our background
and not ashamed.
But I was still ashamed of my
background as a farm worker,
so I never talked about
that part of my life.
DIANE WAGNER: Right.
Let's go back into school.
So early on, you had
some heroes in your life.
And we're going to cover
some heroes in your life
and some villains in the film.
And one other heroes
was Mrs. Lambers.
So when you hear that name,
what do you think about?
RAMON RESA: I think about this
small, little Anglo woman.
I have no idea how old she was.
She was probably in her 20's,
but who knows in those days?
But when I went to school, I
wore the same clothes to school
that I did to work.
And we didn't have hot
running water, so we stunk.
We wouldn't bathe.
And we'd come straight
from the fields
to school, because I would
work in the mornings before
and I would work after school.
But one day, this Mrs. Lambers,
she got down to my level
and she said, you
should go to college.
And why she would say that
to a little Mexican boy whose
family were just farm
workers, have no idea.
But that idea of
college made me realize
that there might be something
out there, whatever that was.
So she put that little
spark in my mind.
DIANE WAGNER: So how
old were you then?
RAMON RESA: I was
in second grade.
DIANE WAGNER: And so you had
no idea what college was.
RAMON RESA: I had no clue.
The teacher said go to
college and I thought, well.
DIANE WAGNER: Well,
thank goodness she did.
RAMON RESA: Yes.
DIANE WAGNER: So now
that you're an adult
and you're where you're
at and you think of her,
what do you think of her now?
RAMON RESA: It's
interesting because I
don't remember much
about my growing up
and the people around me.
I mean, in fact a
lot of times I have
to ask my older relatives
about my teachers,
because I don't remember them.
I don't remember their names.
I have to ask other
people for that.
I have to ask about experiences
we had, because I have a blank.
A lot of blanks.
And in fact, when
I wrote my memoir,
I had to go back and ask
people, who was our teacher?
And then it would start
slowly coming back to me.
But I just think of her as
just that one moment in time.
I mean, it wasn't like
she did that whole year.
It was just a moment in time.
And that's why I was thinking
it's so important when
I talk to people.
I said, you reach a kid at the
right time at the right place,
and you just keep trying.
Because you never know when
the moment will be there.
DIANE WAGNER: Absolutely.
OK, so when you were
in elementary school
and throughout school,
you stuttered badly.
And I assume that
you were teased
and it was really
horrible for you.
Can you talk about that and
what happened with that?
RAMON RESA: Well, I especially
remember in fourth grade,
because we had a fourth
grade teacher, Mrs. Tobin.
I thought she was a witch.
She was a person
with the wily hair
and a hair out of a mole
and the beady little eyes
and she carried a ruler.
She was the one that whacked
me over the head with it
when you spoke Spanish.
But when I was in class, in her
class and she would call on me
and I would stutter, the
other kids would laugh at me,
and so she'd whack them
over the head with a ruler.
And I thought, that's great.
That made me feel good.
But it was really hard to try
to get through school when
you don't speak Spanish very
well and you're stuttering.
And so of course, I
had no self esteem
because of what was
going on at home.
Because at home there
was a lot of abuse going
and a lot of molestations,
a lot of alcoholism.
I mean, we witnessed
people being molested,
we witnessed spouses getting
beat up all the time.
Everybody was
drunk all the time.
That was our environment.
And so I just thought
that that's life.
And so I thought that's the
way I'm going to end up.
And so because of what
was going on at home,
that made me
withdraw and stutter
and not want to be very open.
And throughout all my life,
I was very closed off.
My friends didn't have a clue
what was going on in my world,
inside my head.
DIANE WAGNER: So
you've been very closed
off your whole life?
RAMON RESA: Yes.
DIANE WAGNER: Because of that.
Yeah.
Understandable.
OK, let's talk a
little bit about some
of the racism and discrimination
you suffered in high school.
So one of the villains in
your life, I would say,
is your high school counselor.
Can you tell us a little bit
about that and what happened?
RAMON RESA: Well,
the first time I
met him is when I went in
for college prep courses.
And the first thing I told him
was I want to go to college.
And the first thing he told me
is, you're not smart enough.
Even though I was the
number one student
at the elementary school.
And he said, well, I'm going
to put you in wood shop
like I did your brothers.
That's where you belong.
That's where you people belong.
The implication was
just we were not meant
for anything but field work.
So this man was six
foot five, 250 pounds.
And my grandfather said, you
don't talk back to a white man.
He controls your life,
he controls your destiny,
he controls our jobs.
But I stood up to
him and I said,
I really want to go to college.
And I think that was a
defining moment in my life.
If I hadn't done that, I
wouldn't be here today.
But it's interesting,
because when
you talk about the
discrimination,
I mean, we go out and
work in the fields
and they refused to pay us
after working because they said,
what recourse do you have?
You can't call the
cops because we'll just
have you shipped away
back to Mexico, even
though we were born here.
So [INAUDIBLE] so
they'd tell us they'd
pay us $10 a tray
to pick grapes.
That's how you got paid.
And then at the end of the
day, they pay you eight.
As a Mexican in those
days, you had no justice,
nobody to go complain to.
The last time I really
experienced discrimination
that I've been very vivid is
when I opened up my office
in Porterville and
somebody wrote on my wall,
"Mexican go home."
DIANE WAGNER: They
wrote that before you
opened your office, right?
RAMON RESA: Yes.
They had already put
some [INAUDIBLE]..
DIANE WAGNER: So you
had gone to med school
and you had done your
residency and you
were excited to
start your practice
and right before
you'd opened the door,
they wrote that, right?
RAMON RESA: Yeah.
So throughout life, I mean
in high school and college
and stuff, you could tell
even in elementary school,
even though everybody there was
poor, but if you were Anglo,
they looked at you differently.
I mean, they gave you
the opportunities.
I mean, they would tell
the white kids, OK, now you
lead them because
they're not leaders.
And it was just
amazing that you always
thought that you had to
step behind a white person
even when it was a kid who was
paid for working in the fields
too.
DIANE WAGNER: So you
grow up feeling inferior.
RAMON RESA: I was inferior.
I cannot remember.
Even the medical
school, I always
thought that everybody
was smarter than I was.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
So in high school, you became
very depressed, suicidal even.
So why do you think you got
so depressed in high school?
I mean, obviously we
know a lot of adversity
we've been talking about.
But what specifically
in high school
do you think contributed to the
severity of your depression?
RAMON RESA: I think
in high school
was the first time I really saw
my situation at home for what
it was.
It was so dysfunctional
and so toxic.
And all the stuff
that had been going on
and all the things
that I witnessed.
And then when I stepped
into the classroom
and I saw those kids that
were so different from me.
And then here I am trying
to fit in and I realized,
this isn't me.
This isn't where I belong.
And I mean, obviously
I'd been depressed
my whole elementary
career and life.
And I was just thinking I have
a pipe dream to go to college
and nobody in my family
had even come to college
or even entertained the idea.
So I thought, that's
my only way out
and there's no way
I'm going to go in.
So I just started thinking
about killing myself.
That was just, [INAUDIBLE].
DIANE WAGNER: So how
close did you get to that?
RAMON RESA: Every day I
just thought about it.
Every day I thought, how am I
going to drive off this bridge
or how am I going to
find a way to do it?
And I would leave my
friends for weeks at a time
and not talk to them.
Just function,
just go day to day.
But that's the thing.
Every time I came
back, they would
accept me back for who
I was and say nothing
and ask me no questions.
And I think that's
saved my life.
And I still have
those three friends,
they're still friends
of mine to this day.
DIANE WAGNER: Three friends?
RAMON RESA: Yeah.
DIANE WAGNER: That is amazing.
I think it really speaks
to the power of people
being able to find
a family or you
were able to find
some support that you
didn't have anywhere else.
So you were the
first in your family,
I say in quotes,
to go to college.
And you knew you wanted
But you weren't quite
sure how and you
had no idea what really to do.
So in high school, you had
another hero that came along,
kind of showed you
an opportunity.
Can you tell us a little
about [INAUDIBLE]??
RAMON RESA: Yeah, I mean, in
high school for some reason,
the counselors did not
tell us about college.
The most they would
mention is junior college,
because you could do
carpentry in junior college
and you could do plumbing
and stuff like that.
But one day this young man
showed up named [INAUDIBLE]..
And he said, I can tell you
how you can go to college,
because I'm going
to UC Santa Cruz.
And one of these
days, I'll show you.
I'll take you there.
And so one weekend that I
wasn't working in the fields,
he got a group of us together
from Redwood High School
and we went.
And for the first time in
my life, I saw the beach
and I saw the ocean
and I saw hope.
And I saw this beautiful
campus and I thought, wow,
how do I go here?
And he said, well, you have
to fill out an application
and we need to get
your financial records
from your parents.
So I went back home and
I told my grandparents.
I said, wow, I
can go to college.
I found out a way.
My grandmother
took one look at me
and she said, you bastard,
you're not going anywhere.
You gotta stay here and
get a job at a factory
and pay us back for all the time
and money we invested in you.
I mean, here I supported
myself since the age
of three years of age
and she's telling me
that I can't go away to college.
So I moved out of my
home my senior year
to be able to get away from her.
DIANE WAGNER: So
how did that work?
How did you move
out of your home?
Where would you go?
RAMON RESA: Well, another
person, my biology teacher,
Mr. Nagel, found
out my situation.
So he found me an
apartment near the campus.
And when I tell
people, I tell them
I have had two jobs in my life.
I was a farm worker
and a doctor.
But he also did
something else for me.
He found me a job as a
janitor in my senior year.
So I have to change
what I tell people,
because I was a
janitor a year, and I
was proud to do that because
that helped me support myself
for that whole year.
And I just waited for the
dream of getting the letter
from UC Santa Cruz to see
whether I had been accepted
or not.
And so if it wasn't
for Mr. Nagel,
I'm not sure what
would happen to me.
Homeless or I would have found,
I don't know, something else.
Who knows?
But that was another
defining moment in my life.
Somebody stepped
up and helped me.
DIANE WAGNER: Absolutely.
I mean, you definitely have an
amazing amount of persistence,
but you definitely
also have had angels
that have come in at
key periods of your life
that have helped to
make the difference too.
RAMON RESA: Yes.
DIANE WAGNER: OK, well then
that gets us into college.
So you went to UC Santa
Cruz in the early '70s.
And at that time, the
UC system had a big push
in terms of recruiting Latinos.
Because the UC
system student body
was vastly underrepresented
in terms of Latino students.
So you were among
that first wave.
And can you tell us a little
bit about what that was like?
RAMON RESA: Well, when I
first went to the campus
and I saw it, I
thought it was a park.
I was like, this is a
Disneyland for adults.
Because my life was all
farm work and fields.
And you just step into
it and to go to the dorm
and when people complained
about the dorm being
too small and not
enough room, I thought,
I mean, this is for just
two people, not five.
And the room was bigger than
the room we all slept in.
And we slept on the
floor and all that stuff,
so I thought, wow,
this is fantastic.
And then we had to use sheets.
And I thought, sheets,
what are those?
I mean, I had no idea
how to use sheets.
And then we went to the
cafeteria and forks and knives.
Where are the tortillas?
I mean, I just wasn't
used to eating that way.
It was so foreign to me.
I mean, honestly, it was
just a different world.
I just could not believe
that I had actually
gotten out of my environment
and was in a college situation.
DIANE WAGNER: Did you
feel you were in heaven
or were you in shock?
RAMON RESA: I was in shock.
I was in culture shock.
I mean, I just had no clue
what I was doing there.
I mean, when they told
me about financial aid
and I had my grants and my
loans and how to get the money.
What do you mean how
do I get the money?
Well, you have to put in a bank.
What's a bank?
You have to get a
checking account?
What's a checking account?
So I had no clue how to
do any of those things.
And so I had to learn all that.
And so it was just interesting.
I kept thinking
that every time they
charged me a fee for
something because I
would overdraw my checks.
I had no idea.
I thought they were
stealing money from me.
So I had to learn all of that.
DIANE WAGNER: So it
was a whole new world
in terms of people too, right?
So all of a sudden there
were a lot of girls around.
RAMON RESA: Yes.
DIANE WAGNER: And so had you
dated much until that point?
RAMON RESA: I didn't
date in high school,
because of my self esteem and
the shame I felt for myself
and what was going
on inside of me.
I was afraid to talk to girls.
I just didn't interact
with them at all.
But it was funny because in
my first class in college,
in anthropology, I looked behind
me and I see this gorgeous girl
and thought, wow.
A couple days later, I actually
saw her in the courtyard
and I had the courage
to go up to her.
And I said, are you Mexican?
And she said no.
And I said, that's OK.
[LAUGHTER]
But I knew that I had
fallen in love with her.
And I was going to marry her.
One problem.
She had a boyfriend.
Six foot tall, 200 pounds.
His dad was a doctor in
Marin County in California,
one of the richest
areas in the country.
And so I had to figure
out a way to win her back
and to win her to my side.
And here I am a
scrawny Mexican farm
worker with long
hair and a bandanna
and now I'm more
or less a militant
because I'm realizing
the injustices
that we're suffering.
So I'm competing
with this person.
And about three months
after I met her,
she came up to my
dorm room and I asked
her, what are you doing here?
She says, I want to just let
you know I broke up with Kirk.
And I said, why did you do that?
She said, because I realized
I'm in love with you.
And that's the first
time in my life
I had ever heard those words.
And we've been
married for 41 years.
So I did marry her.
DIANE WAGNER: Wow.
So that was the first time in
your life you had heard that.
And you were what, 18, 19?
RAMON RESA: 19.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah.
RAMON RESA: But even in those
days when I started dating her,
there was a lot of,
like, why are you dating?
Why she dated this Mexican.
She was getting a lot of static
from not so much her family,
but her family kept
saying, are you
sure you know what you're doing?
Because he doesn't know
much about our culture,
he doesn't know how
to go out to eat.
Are you sure you know
what you're doing?
They kept asking
her and asking her.
And they're from Marin
County, a very liberal setting
in California, but
they still kept
asking her if she
knew what she was
doing in an interesting way.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah.
It is interesting,
your backgrounds
are so polar opposite.
You are from central California
and this very poor town
and she was from Marin County
and you found each other
and you chose a very
healthy relationship, which
is incredible, I think,
with your background.
RAMON RESA: Well,
it's interesting
because, again I mentioned
Marin County is very liberal,
but one of their friends,
her parents' friends,
applied to medical school
at the same time I was,
and he didn't get in and I did.
And they were very upset
because they told her,
your daughter's boyfriend
took our son's spot
because he's Mexican.
DIANE WAGNER: Well, so
speaking of medical school,
so when did you decide
to become a doctor?
What happened?
RAMON RESA: When
I started college,
I had no idea what
I was going to do.
I just thought, I'm
in college, and then I
thought, well, now what?
But my mother, I mentioned she
had five kids when she gave us
away.
But she ended up getting
married and had seven more.
And her husband
or my stepfather,
whatever you want to call him,
had an accident in the farm
my freshman year at college.
And he went to the
emergency room.
They told him there's
nothing wrong with him,
go back to work.
He died of a brain hemorrhage.
My Aunt Helen had breast cancer.
She went to see her doctor.
She said, they treated me
like dirt because I'm Mexican.
I'd rather die.
She died.
My brother, Domingo,
he was a sickly kid.
I was in and out of Valley
Children's Hospital in Fresno.
He would be in
there for six weeks
at a time with a GI problem.
And so I thought, wow, maybe
that's what I should do.
I should think about
going to medical school.
So I went up to my
advisor, my counselor,
and I said, I decided
I want to go pre-med.
He said, you're
not smart enough.
He didn't even know who I was.
He didn't have my
transcripts in front of him.
But he just looked at
the color of my skin
and just told me I
wasn't smart enough.
So I dropped him as
my adviser, obviously.
DIANE WAGNER: So
then what did you do?
RAMON RESA: Well, I asked
some people who were pre-med.
And in high school,
I didn't take
any of the pre-med classes.
I didn't take calculus,
physics, or anything like that.
And so the first
thing that did is
I went and signed up for
chemistry and the first thing
I did is I flunked it.
I thought, wow, there
goes that dream.
But I realized, no, I
really want to be a doctor.
So I went back and
I took it over.
And with the help
of tutors, I was
able to pass all my
classes, my physics
and my calculus and
organic chemistry.
And the really interesting
thing about that
is when my son was
at Stanford, he
tutored kids that
were struggling.
He basically paid
it back for me.
DIANE WAGNER: So your son
tutored others like you
who had needed tutoring?
RAMON RESA: Yeah.
So he helped others get
through when peopled helped me.
DIANE WAGNER: In so
many ways, your story
goes full circle
in terms of being
able to see impact like that.
OK, so let's talk a little
bit about med school.
So you went to med school in
the late '70s at UC Irvine.
And you got accepted there,
UC, because you said something
to them when you applied
that you believed really
helped you get in.
What was that?
RAMON RESA: Well, in those
days, medical schools, only 1%
were minority.
And they came up with this
idea of affirmative action
to give some of
us an opportunity.
And again, I didn't
have the best MCATs,
I didn't have the best grades.
But I was able to
get an interview.
And when I went to UC Irvine,
they asked me a question.
And they said, why do
you want to be a doctor?
I said, I want to be a doctor
so I can go back to my hometown
and be a role model for
the kids that remind me
of the kid I used to be.
And I think that's what
got me into medical school.
DIANE WAGNER: So what
happened when you got there?
Did you feel welcomed
or comfortable?
What was that?
Because you said that
there weren't many other
Latino med students.
RAMON RESA: What happened is
that one of the Anglo students
came up to us,
there were a number
of minorities that
were admitted,
and she said, I overheard
the professors talking
and they were saying that
you people don't belong here
and they're going to do
everything in their power
to make you guys quit or fail.
So that was what welcome we had.
And we knew that we had
a target on our backs
and if we did not
succeed, we would not
be able to open up the door
for the people to follow us.
So it was hard.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah, you call
those your zombie years.
So a lot of stress.
RAMON RESA: Very much.
I had no idea what I was doing.
I was just going day
to day and I was hoping
that I just would not fail.
It was interesting, because when
I was thinking about quitting,
I got a letter from my
an aunt of mine, Lucinda.
And in the letter, she said,
Ramon, we knew you were smart
and you would get a job indoors
and wear a suit and tie.
But for you to be a doctor,
for anybody in our family
to be a doctor,
that's impossible.
So I knew I could
not fail my family,
because I needed to be a
role model for them too.
DIANE WAGNER: So things
like this kept you going?
Because I think
oftentimes people
say, well, what's the
key to your perseverance
or what really made
you keep going?
And I think it changed
throughout your life, right?
Things like that would keep
you going at that time.
OK.
Well, people talk about
having a rock bottom.
I know your life is just
completely up and down
a lot of challenges.
So was there a rock
bottom for you?
RAMON RESA: Yes, several.
But after I graduated from
medical school, I went home.
They were having a party.
But the party wasn't for me, it
was for my aunts and sisters.
And my family, they never got
married, they just had babies.
And there were three new babies.
And so when I was there,
I overheard my grandmother
and my mother in the background
saying, my son the doctor,
no, he's my son.
And I was so angry at them
that I went up to them as said,
neither one of you's my mother.
And I went up to Fresno to start
my UC San Francisco [INAUDIBLE]
my internship program.
And while I was there, I was
getting really severe headaches
from the tension.
Kids were dying and I was used
at all these kids dying on us.
But about a month after
I started my program,
I get a call from home.
My sister Annette was married
to an abusive alcoholic man,
just like every single
woman in my family.
And she decided she had enough.
She left him.
Unfortunately, she left him to
go to my brother Danny's house.
And this man followed her there.
Danny tried to stop
him at the door.
He put out a gun,
shot Danny, killed him
in front of his two kids.
Tracked Annette down
into the bedroom,
shot her and killed her
in front of her two kids
and took off to Mexico
never to be seen again.
They gave me two days
off from my internship
to go home for the funerals.
And when I was home, I
realized that in my selfishness
to make something of myself,
I had abandoned my own family.
I wasn't there for them.
So I went back to my
internship program and I quit.
I just said, I can't
take this anymore.
So I quit.
DIANE WAGNER: I can't imagine.
I mean, the family violence
like that and the family guilt
that you had on top of it.
So how did you
rebound from that?
You went back and
then how in the world
would you get back on track
after all that torment?
RAMON RESA: My
wife was pregnant.
And my daughter was born.
And when I held her in my
arms and she looked up at me,
I realized this was
no longer about me.
This was what I
could do for her.
So I went back and I
begged for my job back.
And they gave me my job back.
And every time I wanted
to quit or failed,
I just had to hold my
little girl in my arms.
I said, this is for you.
And I still call her
my little lifesaver,
because if it wasn't for her,
I wouldn't have finished.
DIANE WAGNER: So she
was your lifesaver.
Yeah.
I'm curious about the amount
and the different kinds
of adversity you've had,
the hunger and the abuse
and the discrimination and
just the wide range of things
you had been through.
What do you think
you would say has
been the hardest
throughout your life?
RAMON RESA: I think my
low self esteem has always
been a burden from the get go.
And even through
medical school, I
thought I was the
stupidest, dumbest student.
And in residency, I
always thought I was again
the back of the pack.
And even when I graduated
and I started my practice,
I still thought every
other doctor in town
was smarter than I was.
And I joined Rotary.
I don't know if anybody
knows what Rotary is,
but I joined Rotary and
I became the president
after only being in the
club for three years.
And I thought, what
am I doing here?
I don't know enough
to even run a club,
much less be in front
of them like this.
But the hardest part
was always thinking
that I never was good enough,
I never was smart enough.
And I think once I told my
story in front of my Rotary Club
and they accepted me, because I
never told people about my life
before, that changed me.
I realized I had value.
Being a farm worker wasn't
the end of the world.
It was something that I used
to springboard myself ahead.
And if I could just share all
the stuff that went in my life
with other people
and I could make
them realize that if
they suffered abuse
or if they had no
mother or father or this
was going on, that
they can make it too.
DIANE WAGNER: That
is so powerful,
because I feel like
we all have pain.
We have different kinds
of pain and struggle.
But we tend to hold
it in and maybe move
on or ignore it or not talk
about it because we're ashamed.
And you're speaking to the power
of sharing it, and whether it's
in your Rotary Club or
with a friend or family
member or therapist
or whoever it may be.
And it kind of takes the
power away of the pain.
RAMON RESA: Yes, exactly.
DIANE WAGNER: Yeah.
So your ticket
out was education.
RAMON RESA: Right.
DIANE WAGNER: Obviously.
So do you view education
as a human right?
What's your philosophy
about education?
RAMON RESA: Definitely.
I mean, I think it's ridiculous
when I have kids in my practice
who say they can't go to college
because they can't afford it.
And I'm talking
about Mexican, Anglo.
I mean, it's sad that they
have to make a choice.
And in this world, if
you want to go to college
and you're qualified, you
should be able to go to college.
I just think it's criminal that
when people get out of college,
they owe so much money.
That's wrong.
DIANE WAGNER: How much did you
pay for your kids' educations?
RAMON RESA: My daughter
was $25,000 a year.
So it was $100,000.
And luckily she didn't
go a fifth year.
My son was $200,000 at Stanford.
But I did not pay
for medical school.
I figured he could pay his
own medical school expenses.
DIANE WAGNER: So
that's a sizable bill
that you could do
because you are a doctor
and you achieved
the American dream,
but that's a crazy amount
of money to think about.
RAMON RESA: Yes.
I honestly don't see how
somebody come into a job, oh,
and $100,000 or $150,000 as
a teacher or whatever else
and I mean, it took
me 20 years even
though most of my college
and medical school
were based on loans and grants.
I finished paying
off my college loans
the year before my
daughter started college.
So I've been paying
college a lot of years.
But again, I was
blessed to be able to do
that because of the
education I received.
DIANE WAGNER: And I think
most parents want that.
They want to be able to do that.
So it's just this
issue of is education
affordable and accessible?
OK, so now I'd like to ask
you some fun questions.
And then we're
going to open it up
for questions from the audience.
And what we're
thinking of there,
just so you can kind
of noodle on it,
is we want you to think about
Dr. Resa's life and his story
and maybe the elements of
it that really touched you
and why the story
resonates with you.
OK, so first of all,
you are a good golfer.
So you are what, a handicap
seven or something?
RAMON RESA: Nine.
I'm not that good.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
Well, that's pretty good,
as far as I understand.
RAMON RESA: I think
my practice gets
in my way of my
practicing for golf.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
You took a red eye here because
you wanted to play golf.
RAMON RESA: One more
time with my son.
My son was home and we
played seven rounds of golf
in eight days.
DIANE WAGNER: Right.
OK.
But I hear you get frustrated
on the golf course.
RAMON RESA: Sometimes.
DIANE WAGNER: Sometimes, yeah.
So what would be an embarrassing
golf blow up that you have?
RAMON RESA: I don't
think it's embarrassing.
Just the fact that I throw
my clubs and hit the trees
and they break.
That's not embarrassing.
That's just something I do when
I get angry and frustrated.
DIANE WAGNER: OK, not
embarrassing to you, OK.
Alright.
So you're a
pediatrician and parents
ask you all the
time, well, what do
I do if little Joey doesn't
want to eat his vegetables?
And what do you say?
RAMON RESA: I tell
him I hate vegetables.
Plain and simple.
I say, but somehow both
my kids love vegetables.
So I just tell
them don't push it.
But do what my wife does.
Mince it really, really fine.
And that way I
can't pick it out.
Because if I can pick
out the vegetables,
I don't care how small they
are, I will pick them out.
So she minces it.
So I tell them to mince it.
DIANE WAGNER: To this day.
RAMON RESA: Yes, to this day.
To this day.
DIANE WAGNER: When you
hear the word cadaver,
what do you think?
RAMON RESA: Oh, I just think
of being in the anatomy lab
dissecting the cadaver.
I'm having a sandwich and hoping
that I don't mix the two up.
[LAUGHTER]
DIANE WAGNER: What's your
definition of happiness?
RAMON RESA: Babies.
Kids.
Holding a baby.
That's my all time favorite.
Just after I examine a four or
five month old baby, after I
get done, I just hold them.
And it's just so neat to
just hold them and have
them look at you
and smile and gurgle
and they make little noises.
That's it.
DIANE WAGNER: You
live for babies.
RAMON RESA: I live
for babies and that's
my biggest gripe about my kids.
Jerks.
They will not give
me grandchildren yet.
35 and 30, you'd
think by this time.
My older brother, he's only
older than me by two years.
He already has
great grandchildren.
DIANE WAGNER: Well, we'll
think good thoughts for you.
And then what's the most
disappointing part of your life
right now?
What's really kind of just
bugging you lately these days?
RAMON RESA: Trump.
Politics.
What's going on in this
world and this country.
Really that's it.
I just think that he's going
to have a lot of effect
on a lot of people, like migrant
education programs that benefit
kids, that they may
cut out because he's
going to think, oh, 50
million here or 100 million
here, no big deal.
They don't understand
that in my community,
it's going to
impact those schools
and those children so much.
DIANE WAGNER: And what about
your peer group and things
that you've been seen
lately or hearing?
RAMON RESA: Yeah, I have a lot
of friends who are in Rotary
and are Anglo and are
conservative and Republican.
And we get along really
well and I unfortunately
have been hearing a lot of
more racist remarks from them
than I used to.
So they've been given permission
to open up about their racism
that I thought
didn't exist anymore.
DIANE WAGNER: And they
probably don't realize it
in front of you, right?
I mean, they're
friends with you.
RAMON RESA: Well, they say,
oh yeah, but you're different.
You're an exception.
You're a doctor.
You're not-- like that
makes a difference?
DIANE WAGNER: No,
that must be really
jarring to see that in people
that you know coming out now.
RAMON RESA: Yeah.
It's sad because I thought
this world was changing.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
And then before we get
to the Q&A, one more.
So if you could talk to
your 18 year old self,
what would you say?
RAMON RESA: Honestly, I have
no idea what I would say,
because I can't even fathom what
I was as an 18 year old other
than I was lost.
And I just had hope
about going to college.
I have no idea, honestly, what
I could have said to myself.
DIANE WAGNER: Well, maybe you
could say something like, hang
on, because you'll be good.
RAMON RESA: Who knows?
I don't speculate.
I mean, somebody
asked me one time,
what would you tell your
father if you ever met him?
I have no idea.
I mean, I don't even
speculate about what
happened to my father, where
he is, or what he's done.
I don't think about it.
DIANE WAGNER: OK.
Great.
Well, can we open up for Q&A?
OK.
Who's first?
AUDIENCE: That was a very
powerful presentation.
Thank you so much
for being so honest
and sharing your emotion.
You talked a lot about not
knowing your father, but what
about your mother?
What kind of relationship
did you have with her,
especially after she married and
had seven additional children?
Was she a factor in your life?
RAMON RESA: My
mother was my aunt.
I always thought
of her as my aunt.
Never thought of
her as my mother.
I thought of my half
brothers and sisters
as just more siblings.
I thought my grandparents'
kids, my aunts and uncles,
more as my brothers and sisters.
But even that was kind
of older than I was.
So it was like I was in limbo.
I wasn't sure where I belonged.
My mother lived in
the same town I did,
but she didn't really exist
to me other than [INAUDIBLE]..
DIANE WAGNER: But you
would run into her?
RAMON RESA: At
family get togethers
and maybe on the street,
but I, again, just
didn't relate to her.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much for
your time and for your talk.
So obviously your
legacy is going
to go far beyond the
beginning of growing up
without your paternal
mother and father,
but personally, I have family
members who've been abandoned.
So I even see
firsthand how difficult
it would be for anyone.
And so through
your talk, you just
radiate that you moved beyond
the bitterness and the hurt.
So I guess what helped
you heal beyond the hurt?
RAMON RESA: I think
that when somebody
asked me to write a book
about my life experiences,
I was able to get that out and
open it up and actually see
all the stuff that happened.
And I always said that
before my mother--
I mean, I hated my grandparents
for what they did to us.
But before they died, I
realized that they themselves
had no education.
They had no hope.
They were just
struggling to survive.
And so I was able to
forgive them for that.
And the same thing
with my mother.
I mean, she had five
kids before she was 21.
I mean, she was molested,
plain and simple.
She didn't know what
she was doing either.
So I shouldn't have
blamed her either.
And so I was able
to forgive her.
And before she died, I took
her to a restaurant, the best
restaurant that she had
ever been to in her life,
just kind of take her out.
And two weeks later, she died.
So I had some peace
because I didn't walk away
with bitterness.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
the very powerful story.
I think a lot people would call
your experience the definition
of the American dream.
I want to ask you if
what your definition
of the American
dream is and if you
think that the American dream
is still alive and has a future?
RAMON RESA: Yes,
it is still alive.
I think that the current
administration is stepping
on it on a lot of cases.
But I think that you still are
able to make it in this world
if you try and if
you have support
and if somebody's behind you.
I mean, I don't
know what I would
have been like if
I had some family
support behind me or parents.
I have no idea what
I would have done.
But I think that's
an important thing
and I tell all my
parents in my office
and that I encounter,
just be there
and be supportive
no matter what it
is that your kids want to do.
I had one young man that
was sent to me by the judge
because he was
getting into trouble.
And he didn't want
to go to school
because he didn't like it.
He was carjacking cars
and getting in trouble.
But anyway, so he came in
and I asked him one time,
I said, why are you doing this?
He says, because I
don't like my life.
I said, well what do you
want to do with your life?
He says, I want to be a cook.
I want to go to culinary school.
And I said, why
don't you do that?
I can?
I said, yes.
Well, my parents don't
want me to be a cook.
So who cares what
your parents want?
What do you want?
So he had an adult, a person
of authority, tell him, do
what you want.
All of a sudden,
his eyes lit up.
And that's really what it is.
You just do what's fun.
And I think as long
as you do what's fun,
you are living the
American dream.
I happen to be a
doctor, a pediatrician,
and I love being around babies.
So I am right where I should be.
And in fact, I should
be working right now.
And I can't wait to
get back to work so I
can play with babies again.
And I would tell parents that.
You're paying me to do this?
This is great.
A great job.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Diane.
I'm curious to know as one
of the documentary makers
of "Ramon Rising" how you
came across Dr. Resa's story
and sort of how you went
about putting that together
and what the status is now?
DIANE WAGNER: Thanks.
Yeah.
Well, it's an incredible
opportunity and blessing
to be able to be
making this film,
because it's such
an important story.
And how we came about
it is my husband
Jesse was a media consultant
after spending many years
in TV news.
And during that time,
he was advising people
about how to gain
national news exposure
and so forth on a panel of the
National Speakers Foundation.
And Ramon was there.
He was writing his book,
his memoir, at the time.
And Ramon asked Jesse about
the title "Farm Worker
To Pediatrician."
And Jesse knew at that instant,
that was over 10 years ago,
Jesse knew that that
was just the story.
And long and short, we decided
to make our first documentary
project together
with Ramon's story,
because it goes without
saying it's the perfect story.
So we're in production right
now and we've shot probably
25% of it, maybe 30%.
And we have a few
more weeks of shooting
and a few months of editing.
So we're hoping to get it out
as soon as possible, because it
goes without saying,
I think, but the movie
needs to be out there
for many reasons.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
sharing your story Dr. Resa.
Diane pointed out
in the Q&A with you
that you had some well placed
angels throughout your life.
So what sparks you?
What do you do to
pay it forward?
RAMON RESA: I talk to a lot of
schools, a lot third graders,
fourth graders, high school,
college, kids in trouble,
kids who are losing their way.
In my office, I
talk to the kids.
If they don't perform,
I tell them off.
I say, you're smart.
Don't you dare
tell me that you're
only capable of doing a C.
So I become their role model,
their authority.
If their parents are happy
with them getting a C,
I said, I wouldn't
be happy with that.
So I push them.
And I push other people
when I meet other people
and I talk to other people.
I tell them, this is
all you have to do
to make this kid a success.
Just be there.
Just be there for
that one moment.
I don't like to talk.
I don't like to go all over the
country, all over the state.
But that's what I do.
And I do it because
this young woman
not too long ago, I told
my story and she said,
I had given up hope.
And I heard your
story, now I have hope.
So I realized that even though
I don't want to do this anymore,
there are other people
that will benefit from it.
So I keep going.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned you didn't
want your kids to suffer
the same way that you
did growing up.
So what did you do to
prepare your own kids
against discrimination?
RAMON RESA: Against what?
AUDIENCE: Discrimination.
RAMON RESA: Basically
just being a doctor
and living in a home
with a swimming pool
and not out in
the ghettos or out
in the toxic
environment like I did
or the neighborhood
was a lot of it.
Not letting them
be exposed to it.
I mean, my kids were not
exposed to my family.
They were not exposed to the
abuse and the alcoholism.
They were not exposed
to the negativity
that's going on there.
It was all about positive,
positive, positive role models.
And I was showing them, I mean,
every time we went somewhere,
I showed them colleges.
We go to Santa Cruz,
go to UC San Francisco,
USC, Cornell, Harvard, Yale.
Every time we went on a
trip, we'd stop by the school
and look at them.
And that was just my hope was,
oh, you're going to college.
The question is where, not
are you going to college.
And that's how I
just brought them up.
They had the opportunity
and the ability
to do anything they wanted to.
I never pushed.
I just expected it of them
and they met my expectations.
DIANE WAGNER: You shielded
them, though, from a lot.
RAMON RESA: I mean, my son heard
my talk at Stanford one time.
And I asked my wife
about what he thinks.
She said, he was so mad at you.
Why?
Because you had never told
him any of this stuff before.
So I did not bring my
background into their world.
So they grew up in
the middle class
world that had all the
opportunity open to them.
[APPLAUSE]